season 4 of taylor sheridan's popular
contemporary western yellowstone is well
underway and fans are lighting up reddit
threads with theories about how the
season will play out who will come out
on top and where various characters will
land in the wake of season 3's violent
attack on the duttons but amidst the
speculation there's also been quite a
bit of chatter surrounding one of the
series most volatile characters kelly
riley's beth dutton for the first three
seasons best character came off as equal
parts savvy businesswoman psychological
terrorist fiercely loyal daughter and
emotionally wounded and conflicted
badass
don't look at him
you're dealing with me now
as season 4 plays out however fans have
noticed to their disappointment that
best character is fast moving from
compelling character into the realm of
cartoonish caricature although the
season has made a passing attempt to
give her some depth by an equally
cartoonish look she wants to cook and be
maternal storyline that so far hasn't
really played out for the most part
viewers feel her character's arc has
begun its ascent over the proverbial
shark
[Music]
although outspoken audience members have
provided a litany of reasons for their
newfound dislike of the character one
seen in season 4 episode 6 appears to
have truly galvanized the fate to the
once rooted for fan favorite in the
episode titled i want to be him
patriarch john dutton played by kevin
costner inexplicably seduces an
environmental protest organizer named
summer played by series newcomer piper
parabo even though beth previously
insisted that her father needed to hook
up with someone when she walks into the
kitchen and finds summer there the
morning after her night with jon she
reacts in a way that fans found baffling
her immediate impulse upon seeing a
woman she doesn't know and nothing but
one of her father's shirts is to
threaten her with the chef's knife in a
discussion about the episode on reddit
one user expressed their confusion
posting i'm sorry but wasn't it best
idea for her dad to get some to which
another user replied i think it was the
writer's intention to show best
instability but overall it ended up just
feeling cringy instead another user
echoed the sentiment writing like she's
jealous in a weird dark family secret
way gross
no doubt about it best character has
been spiraling for some time now but
this moment was just too much for many
one user wrote that beth is becoming
quote a caricature of a caricature
another fan in the chat described beth
as turning into taylor sheridan's
dominatrix fantasy while another said
they can't help but feel like she's been
flanderized a reference to the way ned
flanders on the simpsons slowly devolved
into a walking collection of exaggerated
quirks over the years
could you uh nana goat my kid diddly
heads
ah
let's see
the episode and the absurdity of the
knife scene were particularly
disappointing to longtime fans of the
character one user wrote yeah as much as
i love beth and her badassness it's
starting to get a little old i was on
summerside in that scene like really
beth you had to hold her at knifepoint
as the standalone scene best odd running
with summer might have been more
palatable had season four not already
turned fans off from her character
in previous seasons best badassery was
balanced by her calculating pragmatism
in a seeding inner conflict that made
her a compelling and nuanced character
but as far as some fans are concerned
season 4 has turned her into a
one-dimensional cartoon villain nowhere
is this transformation more apparent
than in episode 6 where she sits at a
desk with her feet up smoking the same
way a bond villain would as he slowly
reveals his plans for world domination
not everyone however sees the flattening
of best arc as a misstep one user
speculated i've lost count to the number
of times beth has told her daddy that
she's the only one he can trust is
sheridan setting up beth to be dutton's
brutus it would certainly explain the
intensity and strangeness of best
arguably cringy dialogue and behavior
toward her father it might even
potentially explain her character's
full-blown transition into a
disappointing tv show trope
dad if you're gonna hire a hooker
would you please let me get you a good
one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]